neben der florian dick kommen aus den
gräbern das ist bei hollabrunn
ich bin im oktober 2016 eingerückt den
retro zwei der flughafenfeuerwehr in
langen leberfunktion wie brandschutz
gehirn bei der flughafenfeuerwehr und
unsere aufgabenbereiche ist die piloten
rettung auslandszeugen die
brandbekämpfung
ich habe mal ausdrückt die flugausfall
bin privat aber der freude und habe
durch diese interesse so der feuerwehr
einige von meinen bekannten verschattung
und deswegen auch und die entscheidung
hohe eigene show daher muss so weit
gehen dass wir herkommen winter
funktioniert also wir haben geübt den
normierten deutschland größte witz
verwendet bei einer flugzeugbauers und
den immer öfters damit man schnell sein
bei markus noch als dass der pilot
erfolgreich geräte irgendwo die
schwierigkeit von einsatz von jeglicher
realität zum beispiel ruhig bleiben
dieser trend westermeier und da irgend
heute bist du nervös und dann kann man
die dinge nimmer so klasing und deswegen
ist es ist wichtigste eigentlich also
unser typische tagesablauf um halb acht
das flugzeug beginnt ein zerstörtes
fahrzeug überprüft auslösen hamburg
machen wir morgen check und überprüfen
die fahrzeuge als ihre funktion war das
erledigt haben so für wartungs und
reinigungsarbeiten beide fahrzeuge durch
also bis jetzt 26 uhr wieder einrücken
wieder zurück wieder herkommen
[Musik]